alright guys I am here with Murad we are
going to do our best to create a podcast
episode that becomes the de-facto
episode you can send to people when they
ask what is Bitcoin and why is it
important so Murad tall task in front of
us but thank you for coming thank you
for having me Anthony pleasure to be
here absolutely alright so before we get
into this let's go through your
background and then we kind of jump into
everything
sure so I'm originally from Azerbaijan
was until recently an international
student here in America got into Bitcoin
quite heavily
after spending a semester abroad in
China during the previous bubble in late
2013 early 2014
a lot of the exchanges back there as you
may know still didn't have sort of
tremendous liquidity yet and some of my
foreign friends were sort of trading
Bitcoin p2p sort of bringing in in into
China selling it at cetera so attended a
bunch of Beijing meetups sort of being
in the rabbit hole since and made a
small pause as many of us have in like
up to 2015 and then as 2016 rolled and
sort of got back into the this game
briefly worked in finance and then sort
of now doing several different crypto
things full time absolutely ok and so
let's just start with the simplest
question right what is Bitcoin this is a
very good question and a Bitcoin is
something that can be described with
more than a hundred different
definitions and a lot of people debate
what they are but to me personally
Bitcoin
first and foremost is a new form of
money and it's a new form of thinking
about money storing money transferring
money and just dealing organizing an
understanding money and sort of all
kinds of sort of second-order financial
effects that come out of that absolutely
so let's walk through some of the core
components of
Bitcoin right it's obviously it's built
on a blockchain and then it is divisible
it's fungible it's you know all these
things what are the important components
to you
so blockchain is definitely one of the
components a lot of people think that
that's the core one but really that's
one out of four or five core moving
pieces I don't want to give the term
blockchain too much legitimacy right now
because it's really been over abused I
would say and up up to this point it has
become little other than a marketing
term at this point I mean I'm not as
fascinated with blockchain as I am
fascinated with a Bitcoin blockchain but
as I've said there are many moving parts
another is sort of the proof-of-work
function of of Bitcoin in the and how
the time stamping and the security come
into play in this regard bitcoins
governance in particular is very very
unique and very very complex and sort of
hard to understand hard to explain but I
just want to underline the fact that
it's not just a currency on a blockchain
it's really sort of very very
interdisciplinary and multivariable
phenomena where a lot of different
things come into play and blockchain is
merely one out of several absolutely so
let's go into a proof-of-work right how
does that work right and why is it
important peripheral work is very
important because it is the first
workable in my opinion solution to the
double spending problem at scale as we
know a lot of different alternative
currencies and alternative money forms
were created in the 90s in the early
zeroes unfortunately though they didn't
work quite well because most of them
were centralized more often than not of
course and when something is centralized
is is very easy to shut down a privilege
of creating and controlling your own
money let alone a monopoly
on it is something that gives sort of
the controller's of that system a
tremendous amount of power arguably more
than anything else in the world with
Bitcoin proof-of-work once again coupled
with several other things allows the
system to be secure and decentralized at
scale as well as allows us to timestamp
transactions on the ledger in a sort of
decentralized trustless or rather trust
minimized manner which allows Bitcoin
for the first time to be a an
alternative monetary system and an
alternative currency which is several
orders of magnitude much harder to shut
down to censor to stop and to manipulate
than any other project of a similar
variety that has ever arrived in the
past absolutely and so this idea of the
decentralization right in a centralized
world whether it's the traditional
banking system or other attempts like
digi cash Hashcash be money etc the
centralized versions don't have the
double spending problem right so the
double spending problem is this idea if
I have a single US dollar physical
dollar and I give it to you
I no longer have a dollar that I can
give to anyone else right so I only can
spend that dollar one time in a digital
currency the actual unit of value is a
digital file right and it can be copied
and so therefore the problem that many
of these early attempts to build a
digital currency right into the double
spend problem you described and that was
where I give you one unit of value one
Bitcoin and then I would be able to send
that exact same unit of value to
somebody else
therefore spending it twice double
spending it right right the blockchain
right structure is what solved this and
so do you think that the solving of that
double spend problem is why Bitcoin has
been able to thrive
and other previous attempts didn't or do
you think it's something else
so technically centralized currencies
and centralized financial systems have a
double spent problem as well however in
order to solve it you need to we need to
place our trust in a central party in a
centralized Authority who sort of often
control the transactions they control
the settlement they control the issuance
of the currency they control many
different things right Satoshi in one of
his earliest sort of posts on the cipher
cyberpunk email list he noted that the
traditional currencies have several sort
of layers of trust that you have to sort
of essentially give into in order to use
the system you need to trust the central
bank's not to dilute the currency too
much you need to trust commercial banks
that they're going to let your
transactions through etc etc etc right
and the the amazing thing with Bitcoin
is that now in a very very unique way
Satoshi Nakamoto has managed in a very
elegant way sort of combined several
innovations together
one of which is preferred work Hashcash
together with sort of a chain of blocks
as well as several other things that we
can get into to create a digital
currency where the double spending
problem is solved in a trustless manner
and in which sort of this allows as Nick
Szabo says for the system to be much
more socially scalable than anything
else we've had before and a lot of sort
of anthropologists have argued that sort
of expanding social scalability with
various technologies that allow us to
sort of connect with as many people as
possible in a way where we don't have to
sort of rely on any single party with
with more and more inversions of this
sort we can really sort of expand the
horizons of commerce and the human
civilization at large absolutely and so
you know there's previous attempts at
this all either had a lack of adoption
or they had technical problems right
they there was issues that they couldn't
solve
one of the things that often doesn't get
talked about with Bitcoin is the
governance right so everyone is focused
on the technology itself and kind of how
that is executed what is so special
about the governance of this digital
currency so governance of Bitcoin is not
formally defined and I would argue that
in a way it is a strength rather than a
weakness
technically the governance has to do a
lot sort of with the Bitcoin improvement
processes and how those get proposed and
how those get reviewed how those get
added in etc it's a very conservative
extremely meticulous process which I
consider is strength a lot of people
consider that a lot of people complain
that bitcoin is not evolving or bitcoin
is too slow and to me those people are
sort of exhibiting high time preference
and impatience
I think the alt coin boom and the the
ICO boom a lot of the blockchain boom as
well and sort of has its origins in part
because of this true bitcoiners
understand that this isn't a six year
get-rich-quick scheme but it can be a 80
year project and it's something that
perhaps will continue going on until the
the end of our lives and so every
changes to the system need to be
extremely extremely careful I like to
compare it to like a nuclear reactor or
a heart surgery or like a moon mission
because there's a lot at stake a hundred
billion more than a hundred billion
dollars already and potentially truly in
tens of trillions of dollars someday
right and so this because it is software
it it lends itself to flexibility this
malleability has allowed us to create a
money that is harder and sounder than
gold and and fiat of course but at the
same time this malleability is also
makes it fragile in a number of other
ways and sort of because of this and
precisely because of the software we
need to be extremely careful but
the governance process of Bitcoin is
what PR HR calls a p2p anarchic Network
governance and the fact that it is slow
to change it's something that really
makes Bitcoin far far stronger than
everything else and the number one
reason and I can give dozens of reasons
but the number one reason why alt coins
are far far behind Bitcoin is precisely
because they are much more centralized
in relative terms and everything about
it is much easier to change and
currencies first and foremost are all
about trust as I like to repeatedly say
these crypto assets are unlike many
people sort of in the VC world San
Francisco California they think of these
things as software platforms they try to
apply the late zeroes early ten sort of
tech paradigms to this thing but really
to me it's a monetary phenomenon in in a
very loose terms I like to describe
these things as digital monetary metals
to me that's sort of arguably the
closest metaphor for now I like to even
say that they aren't Bitcoin being
compared to digital gold is an
understatement and really what it is is
digital monetary nuclear weapons because
if you really dig into the third and the
fourth order game theoretic effects that
are likely to arise when this thing gets
just a little bit bigger which to me it
inevitably will there is just so much
that it is going to cause and reorganize
in this world absolutely and so you know
one thing that I think about a lot is if
you were to draw a spectrum and on the
left side you have the slow development
cycles and kind of carefulness of
Bitcoin and on the right side you have
optimization for innovation right and I
think that bitcoin obviously is pretty
far on the left side of that spectrum
and a lot of the icos and alt coins etc
or
on the right side right they want to
quickly build something they want to get
it out there trying and experimenting
and innovating and doing all these
things and so what ends up happening is
because bitcoins speed of development is
slower more methodical kind of more
intentional it can pull from the things
that work on the innovative end and it
can avoid the landmines of the things
that don't work right do you agree with
that
I agree with that and I would even add
that sort of the a lot of people who
started out coins or sort of gotten into
that wave in the last couple of years
come from the technology world or the
startup world venture world and sort of
one of the schools of thought ie move
fast and break things it it completely
does not work for cryptocurrencies
because once again this is not like a
dog walking app or our dating app or
like a food picture app right and you
need to be extremely extremely careful
with this and we want to make it so that
a huge chunk of the world financial
system eventually gets absorbed into
this one digital currency and so
conservatism is definitely the way to go
here some people would even argue that
we need to even be more careful and
review even in an even slower fashion
but I definitely agree with you that
Bitcoin can definitely take whatever if
there's ever something that is actually
useful and truly innovative that any
outgoing does better in any capacity or
function a Bitcoin can eventually adopt
that for sure however and this is why I
believe that sort of privacy coins or
coins with more programmability etcetera
etc they really don't stand a lot of
they don't stand a chance against
Bitcoin at this point in time because I
believe people will soon realize the
truth and the truth is that the value
and aka the price is determined by the
monetary premium and the monetary premia
is determined by a combination of the
current monetary Network effects
monetary liquidity sale ability
marketability recognizability The Linde
effect and most first and foremost the
credibility of the monetary policy
and just the general trust and in all of
these term in all of these criteria
bitcoin is so far ahead than everything
else that the way I see it yes there
there may be two or three more sort of
mini alt coin bubbles particularly as
more people sort of enter into the space
there's a natural sort of incentive to
sort of find the next big thing of
course but I believe that once Bitcoin
goes above several trillion dollars or
so a big divergence will happen and
really all the other cryptocurrencies
will be similar to what penny stocks are
to the big caps in the equity world
right now got it and so would it be fair
to say that if you take that same
spectrum on the left side you've got
security and on the right side you have
you know low levels of security Bitcoin
conservatism pushes it on the extreme
end of the left side around security
right and do you think that these other
blockchains tokens etc are lacking focus
on security or do you think they're
making a rational trade-off between
security and let's call it innovation or
something like that I think it's a
rational trade-off and the reason for
that is because if you even want to
compete in Bitcoin in any capacity then
you it's really difficult to compete
against it in terms of sort of monetary
disinflation which really is the most
important thing here what was it so what
you're saying is if somebody wants to
compete against Bitcoin right another
project you can't beat it on security
today right because of the network
effect and then you can't beat it on the
monetary policy and therefore you have
to go to other areas in which you may be
able to build a competitive advantage
that is most of the thinking in in sort
of eloquent Creators heads and i believe
that it might it it has worked a little
bit and not really it might even work a
little bit in the upcoming waves but it
is doomed to fail eventually it's like
winning the second or third most
important aspect right it's like saying
look the most important thing around so
here it's like six or seven
right yep yeah it's it's super
interesting okay so let's talk about the
design of Bitcoin right so obviously
there's proof of work there's governs
etc but but the actual monetary design
walk us through kind of the
disinflationary and deflationary nature
of the actual design so before before I
delve into that I will say and I think
this is something that people will
increasingly realize in the coming years
uncensor ability school uncie's
abilities cool as well but to me these
really are perks in terms of like the
price going up and this thing taking
over the world if we create a pie chart
the 90 percent a ie the dominant force
which we'll be doing that is bitcoins
monetary policy and really it's
unprintable t the fact that nobody can
print beyond 21 million that is by far
the strongest and the most important
innovation really here okay so the
monetary policy of this system is by far
the most important part precisely and
people need to use something as money
yep right now some of the better
currencies are the US dollar euro the
Swiss franc etc but really people use
those because essentially they're
peaking there they're picking the least
bad thing
I believe the supply of the US dollar in
the last year has increased by six point
two percent bitcoins spoke to flow ratio
today is around three point eight
percent and after the next having if you
go off of the 21 million number it's
going to be one point seven percent and
actually I believe that that switch from
sort of low three percents to high one
percents is going to be the number one
sort of driver of the next big wave in
the twenty in 2020 but to answer your
question more directly
unlike other currencies which their
respective central banks in the case of
Fiat Kim print essentially whenever they
want and as well as they're sort of
respective local commercial banks can
create more of when
issuing that Bitcoin is limited to
strictly 21 million units some of them
it is believed that the several million
have already been lost
I believe that when all is said and done
the global supply of Bitcoin is going to
be somewhere between 16 and 17 million
the fact that nobody can print beyond
the 21 million limit and the fact that
the users the miners and essentially the
everybody in the developers everybody
who has as little as one Satoshi of
Bitcoin they are incentivized in having
that rule be the number one and the most
important sort of rule and the number
one focal point the number one selling
point which the community is gathered
around and really this is the number one
thing which allows Bitcoin to
continuously increase in value and
people are already pricing in its
extreme scarcity I like to say we've
never had an object let alone a money as
scarce as Bitcoin before even gold is
expanding at a rate of around 1.6
percent per year over the last 10 years
now I believe that after it by the late
2020s that number for Bitcoin is going
to be lower than 1% and it is every year
is getting lower and lower so
technically that number is getting lower
every ten minutes and as you might know
every four years there's a particularly
additional sharp drop as well and so I
believe that that sound is that hardness
of currency isn't palpably felt by
people yet and even a lot of
participants in in the market a lot of
sort of traders and investors they don't
really quite grasp this aspect yet but I
believe that this this is the
revolutionary thing here and this is why
I believe Bitcoin is going to be in the
hundreds of trillions in today's terms
in the future so there's a couple of key
terminology and you know components that
you just described right so there's the
total supply of bit
right so when it's all said and done 21
million bitcoins we can get into why
that is and if that could change or not
later but for right now let's just say
there's 21 million total supply of
Bitcoin at the same time there is the
circulating supply so how many bitcoins
have been produced and are currently
available for ownership you know by
people or organizations and then what we
see is every 10 minutes every block
there are more Bitcoin that are added to
the circulating supply but that 21
million fixed supply never never changes
and so what occurs is the
disinflationary right so so yes the
circulating supply continues to expand
until it reaches that 21 million but
that number goes down every four years
or so right in terms of how many
bitcoins every 10 minutes are added to
the supply so that's a disinflationary
model what you described is once all 21
million bitcoins have been mined or are
now part of the code of circulating
supply we now get into a deflationary
model right and so it's do longer
disinflationary because actually there's
no more being added and now we can only
go reverse we can only lose Bitcoin in
the circulating supply right and so
let's talk about the pros and cons of an
inflationary system and the pros and
cons of that deflationary system right
because I don't think I think people
hear these terms but I don't really know
what they mean or or why there's there's
pros and cons either side we're taught
in a lot of schools and sort of the
contemporary mainstream neo-keynesian
economists argue that mild inflation is
best to me I think that sort of
governments around the world
particularly in the Western world are
incentivized for that kind of academic
discourse to be the dominant one in even
in the best institutions and in my
research I found that there's a lot of
sort of academic grants and academic
sponsorships financing that central
banks and ministries of Finance
Ministry's of economics at cetera that
allocates to
of certain schools of monetary thought
than others
but I believe that sir those currencies
are local monopolies and those
currencies are forced upon us from top
down bitcoin is a free-market phenomenon
I would argue that bitcoin is an
experiment in Austrian economics that so
far in its 10 years of existence is
succeeding massively my belief is that
money is a product just like anything
else and I think we will not have truly
pure capitalism and truly pure free
markets until money which is a product
that we utilize which is a product which
is a half of every single transaction in
our society is something that is
originates from the free market as well
I believe that money is ultimately a
product of the market rather than a
product of the state and I think the
last 47 years in history have sort of
are a temporary phenomena for thousands
of years gold was the predominant money
or gold and silver were the predominant
two currencies around the world until
sort of the paper notes became more
widespread as a technology you can think
of paper notes as a layer to technology
on top of money on top of monetary
metals and at that point once you had
paper notes which sort of were
redeemable for metals there was no
longer the divisibility problem of gold
was solved so the need for solar was
drastically reduced and thus silver was
demonetized further it's very
interesting to look at the gold sort of
silver a sort of price ratio and after
1881 you see sort of gold skyrocket in
silver terms but I believe that
something similar will happen with
Bitcoin versus all other monetary
instruments and even other financial
assets which is really which is really
quite eerie I think that when all is
said and done Bitcoin will be
the second or the third single biggest
asset class the single biggest asset in
the world may be real estate will be the
only one bigger and sort of this is my
reasoning around this right now
it is believed that the total money
supply of all fiat currencies around the
world is somewhere around 80 trillion
dollars mm-hmm
if you consider m1 m2 m3 or if you add
them all up around the world and I
strongly believe that that number is
artificially diluted and artificially
kept small because essentially by
continuously printing government's our
disincentivizing the world and this
incentivizing investors and even average
people to store or too much money in
currencies and they're doing this
because if I take $100 and I put it my
bank account as they print money that
$100 loses purchasing power every single
year for sure I mean every single day
where the money creation occurs see it's
interesting because the cost of creating
that money for the government is near
zero it all it takes is just a per PI
push of a button right but essentially
every single unit of fiat currency that
gets created reduces the wealth of the
fiat holder around the world and bitcoin
is an unimaginably new phenomena where
for the first time
nobody can seize your wealth not just
directly like they did with gold in the
30s but just like they do with stealth
inflation in fiat nobody can print more
and for the first time you have this
currency that you can have full or at
least very strong confidence that for
the rest of your life the percentage of
the money supply of this entire system
will always remain the same which really
is completely unprecedented because even
with gold you don't have that mm-hm and
so here's the thing the total amount of
wealth that is stored in currencies is
artificially small people essentially
the system doesn't want us and doesn't
want people to have a good robust
unseasonable store of value because if
that were to
exist then governments and central banks
would lose a tremendous amount of sort
of senior rich privileges because every
time they print
they said they essentially enrich
themselves at the expense of everyone
else a little bit right and so this
current system because the money is
constant getting diluted people like
surgeons artisans dent dentists etcetera
engineers they either have to play
part-time investors on the side or they
have to sort of outsource those services
to registered investment advisers and
brokers etcetera and that's part of the
reason why the financial system is much
bigger than it has to be and why Wall
Street is is is just a ginormous part of
the world's economy if we had something
like gold or better yet Bitcoin then you
could save your wealth and it would
actually gain a little bit of purchasing
power every year without having to sort
of have this anxiety riddled wave of
activities that you need to do and it's
it's actually quite crazy how in today
I'm not even talking about the second or
third world where this isn't even an
option even in the first developed
civilized Western world you have to
create a diversified portfolio of
equities bonds small caps Moonies
commodities F X derivative sometimes etc
just to preserve your wealth I'm not
even talking about making some
tremendous outsized returns I'm talking
about just to save your wealth and this
is crazy and like in biblical times
there's a comp there is a famous Jewish
proverb which says keep a third of your
wealth and money which was gold keep a
third of your wealth in land and keep a
third of your wealth in your business
and even as recently as in the 50s and
60s you could notice that in portfolio
allocations some of sort of the
traditional mutual funds and the the the
the early big asset allocators they had
a much bigger allocation to cash when
sort of the trust and currency was much
greater and you saw that reduced as
years went by and in recent decades with
quantitative easing essentially the
trust in currencies gets incremental II
reduced but I believe that if Bitcoin
were to become global money which I
believe it will or something like it
definitely will because genies out of
the bottle and sort of the idea is here
to stay forever
the percentage of people's average
portfolio that will be in cash as
opposed to today will be a much greater
perhaps not a third but it will be much
higher than it is today and much closer
to a third and in us today and precisely
because of that I believe that the total
wealth in the world that is held in a
currency and note this one currency will
not be inhibited by inflation it will
not be inhibited by borders it will not
be inhibited by centralized control all
these things will contribute to it being
the single biggest currency in the world
and I think that eventually I
increasingly believe that the
cryptocurrency market even soon not just
in the future long-term equilibrium it
will be a winner-take-all rather than a
winner take most game and I believe that
Bitcoin as it currently stands will
probably take 94 to 95 percent of this
entire market so there's a lot here to
unpack and I think it's really important
right what you're describing is the idea
an inflationary model like what we have
with the US dollar for example
incentivizes me to get out of cash right
and get into either hard assets or to
spend that capital because if I hold it
it loses value right and so that
inflationary model for many people they
spent or they take that cash and they
buy real estate or they buy other
investment opportunities because they
know that they have to at least do
better than 2% right on the on their
yield for the year because if they leave
it in cash they're gonna lose 2% right
give or take based on inflation and so
the argument that you're making here is
let's take I don't know 5 10 20 30 % of
the real estate market is actually
wealth preservation right and if people
were given the choice rather than buy
real estate they would rather take that
exact same value and hold it in the cash
equivalent right they don't do it
because today that loses money but if
there was a global digital deflationary
currency
the real estate total market cap which
shrink because people would move from
real estate back into that global
currency and this would not only happen
in real estate but in a number of kind
of store of value type asset classes
where people today find safety to get
out of cash and preserve wealth but that
may not be true in the future precisely
and I think that this really the market
for the global total addressable market
for monetary instruments is a zero-sum
game for Bitcoin to win other things
have to lose other currencies or other
assets over both currencies both both
and that is part of the reason why I
believe that Bitcoin the single currency
will be bigger than in sort of in in
their quote unquote market cap or in the
amount of wealth that is stored inside
it will be greater than not just any but
all of current fiat currencies and
monitor metals added together because I
believe that bitcoin is such a good
store of value that it will take more
than 95% of the current market cap of
fiat currencies it will take more than
75% of the current market cap of
monetary metals and then and this is
sort of the interesting part I think
because the current fiat currencies are
inflationary a lot of high net worth
individuals and asset managers around
the world use the stock market use the
fixed income markets use the real estate
markets as a store of value that is part
of the reason why if you try to buy an
apartment in Tokyo London or New York
the prices are insane and this is
because both American high net-worth
individuals and foreign high net-worth
individuals use these sort of prime city
luxury apartments as one of their stores
of value and I believe that sort of
because uh they the fiat currencies are
constantly diluted at the same time this
has caused an artificial sort of
increase in the value of other asset
classes and other financial instruments
as people are hunting for yield the
aggressive sort of quantitative easing
and the aggressive sort of unorthodox
negative interest rate monetary policies
of some central banks since the
financial crisis have exacerbated this
effect even further and if you look at
the inequality and in the Gini
coefficient it has increased sharply
since 2008 in the last ten years even
more one of the reasons for that out of
several I mean it of course it's a very
multi very topic but one of the reasons
is because the working class and the
lower classes they mostly store their
wealth in cash most of them live paid to
paycheck and whatever savings they have
they do keep it in cash just for
simplicity sake now the asset owners are
those who own real estate stocks bonds
etc and a lot of the wealth has flown
there and a lot of people although
essentially the people who've benefited
the most from this grand wealth effect
experiment are people who are holding
these assets and me much of the time it
is the central banks and themselves who
are indiscriminant in price and
sensitive buyers of these financial
instruments well so this is important
because there's a thought process that
inflation is merely the act of stealing
wealth from the poor and enriching the
elite and wealthy right and so what that
means is if you have paycheck to
paycheck and you leave a high percentage
of your net worth in cash then every
year you're losing value or you're
losing purchasing power but if you
actually have other assets and a lot of
them inflation continues to drive the
price of those assets up and therefore
those that own non-cash assets actually
benefit drastically from inflation and
are incentivized to keep the party going
right and so if you switch to a
deflationary model actually the people
with the preference to have a high
percentage of their net worth in the
currency will benefit drastically and
those in non-cash assets will actually
not benefit in this scenario for sure
and I
I like to describe Bitcoin and sort of
this entire sort of phenomena as a grand
wealth transfer event and I believe that
it will be arguably the single biggest
wealth transfer event in human history
it will be a wealth transfer from the
old to the young from the tech savvy to
sort of the more conservative from the
open-minded sort of the more
closed-minded and of course from the
people who will be holding these crypto
assets and most of all Bitcoin in the
losing side in this case would be people
holding fiat currencies gold etc
absolutely so let's say that everything
you've described is true right and this
is and you just laid out the blueprint
for how this is gonna play out over the
next decade two three four decades right
how big is the opportunity right what is
the market cap of Bitcoin ten or twenty
years from now so so like before before
I answer that question I'll say that as
Bitcoin let's say in six to eight years
from now as it it's a bit bigger are
much more volume much more Linde effect
much more trust much more credibility
etc much more mainstream people will
simply compare two things and Bitcoin
will be in a free-market battle against
fiat currencies and gold simultaneously
and even other things when you just
isolate the store value component as we
have discussed people will simply say
okay this thing is expanding at 6% per
year in its supply and this thing is
expanding at 1% per year in its supply
which one should I pick as a store of
value and that's why to me so that this
feedback loop is inevitable it will be
so difficult to stop the math becomes
undeniable it's it is really if you sort
of extrapolate this phenomena and
extrapolate this sort of wave of
financial change Bitcoin will be a black
hole that will absorb a tremendous
amount of value
I believe the total addressable market
is somewhere between 100 and 200
trillion I like to say it will be a
hundred and sixty trillion so if Bitcoin
and that is if we go off of the ten
million dollars per Bitcoin price in
today's terms with
even counting the sort of the inevitable
hyperinflation of fiat currencies and so
this is my reasoning so - you think that
a single Bitcoin will be worth ten
million dollars in today's money mm-hmm
yes I do and which would give us a
market cap of what like a hundred
hundred and sixty trillion right now the
current market cap of Bitcoin is 110
billion I believe when this bear market
is done give or take will bottom some
around eighty billion and so that's a
2000 X that is still possible between
right now and what is probably our death
and I think like that is there's still a
tremendous opportunity here and I think
high net worth individuals a more sort
of edgy open-minded tech-savvy
institutions and eventually government
institutions will will push this to the
extreme these are big numbers you're
talking and you realize that very few
people in the world believe what you
believe right now I realize that but if
you spend sort of months and months
studying this it sort of becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy to you I'm very
confident I'm very confident Bitcoin
will be bigger than the US dollar and
potentially even bigger than all of them
combined because there's a interesting
table that Vijay boy a party has made
and he says that crypto currencies or
Bitcoin in particular are harder to tax
harder to seize easier to transfer
easier sort of harder to steal easier to
sort of cheaper easier faster to send
around the world they are borderless
they are sort of uber competitive
they're highly deflationary it's such
and there's like there's dozens and
dozens of reasons and all of these
combined I believe will make Bitcoin
incredibly big similar to what the gold
standard was in the late 19th century
but given the fact that the economy is
much bigger today and given the fact
that it is digital and sort of much more
fluid I believe it will be far far
greater than even that and yeah that's
my these are my thoughts absolutely so
let's talk about this idea of
hyperinflation and the fiat currency
expiry
our experiment right so 1971 was it
Richard Nixon right takes us off the
gold standard the gold standard being
the thought process that for every paper
currency every US dollar you could go
and redeem the equivalent in gold right
he was being held in the central banks
at the time what a lot of people don't
realize is Richard Nixon said we're
gonna go back to the gold standard it
was a temporary decision right or at
least asked how they was presented and
so we obviously didn't and since 1971
what we have seen across the world at
different times in different locations
is fiat currencies start to fail right
and these fiat currencies where they
appear to be failing most is in regions
or countries where a government or the
overseen organization loses discipline
right and the thought process is in the
developing world we have much more
discipline right there's checks and
balances and the Fed can't press the
print button too much right because
there's those checks and balances but in
let's say a country where a dictator
comes into power there's less checks and
balances there's a higher probability
that they will lose discipline that you
can hidden a print button too much and
you get into hyperinflation devaluing of
the currency and we know how that ends
right let's talk about that
hyperinflation period why are we seeing
this in the countries we're seeing it
today right and do you think that this
is gonna happen to every fiat currency
in the world why or why not I believe
it's a combination of incompetence as
well as outright grasping for power okay
and I do believe that this will
eventually happen to all fiat currencies
around the world but it will happen sort
of stage by stage of course the second
and the third world currencies will be
the first to collapse and sort of the
more established euros and dollar the
leak from sort of the the financial leak
from there to towards Bitcoin will be a
bit more gradual it will be more like an
curved and then it will reach a point
where the money will just like rapidly
flowing rapidly flow into Bitcoin
because people will as I've described
people will simply realize that this
money is harder than the other one the
other money there's people behind it and
these people can do whatever they want
however this is governed by such a
strong unbreakable algorithm and the
community of people sort of
strengthening it that the the I believe
the sort of the credibility and the
faith and the trust in Bitcoin relative
to fiat currencies will keep growing and
as I've said in the beginning currencies
and sort of the cognitive monetary
premium that's placed atop them is first
and foremost is about trust and it's
about credibility Swiss the Swiss franc
for example people like it because the
Swiss don't print too much they they
have sort of three hundred years of
credibility they have they have
temperance they have discipline as you
have described a lot of sort of in it's
important a safety new moves in in his
work he often says that hyperinflation
has never occurred with metals because
there are natural limits to creation and
there are natural sort of free market
balances there but it's in 99% of cases
it has occurred with fiat currencies
because they are at the behest of humans
and Geor goethe huisman who's arguably
the most prominent Austrian economist
today in the world he says that sort of
this money supply inflation has
traditionally been the means of
financing war but as of late it has
become it's not just used in in wartime
it's been being used perpetually and I
like to say that so
this inflation it essentially shifts
some activity from long term projects
and long term capital goods production
to more sort of short-term consumption
I'm a believer that it is not the
consumption that really drives the
sustainable long term growth of the
economy the kind that actually increases
our quality of life but rather us
engaging in long term projects the long
term capital goods production long term
production of tools instruments research
innovation
things like that and really the best
things that have you ever been created
they were 10 20 30 year efforts rather
than sort of us going and buying
something useless right and so I believe
that if we have a currency that's more
deflationary well people will be
incentivized instead of thinking instead
of going out there and as you've
described investing in something else or
even buying like a pack of crisps or
just new shoes or really something that
it's really useless right now instead
people will be just due to the
deflationary nature of it it will be
seen and felt as more precious people
will be more incentivized to eight save
and be invest in long term projects and
long term sort of craft absolutely and
so I think with the this hyperinflation
right what we're seeing for maybe the
first time or one of the first times
humans have a choice do I trust the
machines the software code the math
right and the algorithms or do I trust
the humans and as more people elect to
take fiat currency and convert it to
Bitcoin they are electing to trust the
machines over the humans right and I've
described this before as the machines
are unbiased emotional they're
disciplined and they do what they're
supposed to do the humans are
undisciplined and greedy and when you
lay it out that way I think this is
gonna happen in a lot of different
facets of our life right
you already see some of this with you
know the advent of uber and that type of
stuff
but with money specifically the problems
arise from human lack of discipline and
therefore as more people trust the
machines they are rewarded because money
acts how money's supposed to act agree
or disagree definitely I definitely
think we will see a similar phenomenon
in different sort of facets of
technology and capitalism as a whole and
as I've sort of described in the
beginning Bitcoin I don't want to use
the word entirely trustless because
there are still certain things we can
trust but they are far far more
distributed and in my opinion harder to
change than sort of centralized
solutions and this allows commerce to
happen on a global scale and this allows
you to trust this payment rail like
never before
Bitcoin is extremely secure and it
allows us to I believe that another
thing that it will do to finance is it
will eliminate the forex industry
completely because if we only have one
global currency instead of these dozens
of currencies that we have today
hundreds of currencies then the foreign
exchange market will cease to exist
because we will just have one currency
Hans Hermann hop ad describes the
current sort of state of affairs and
state of fiat currencies as a mild state
of barter whenever one company or one
corporation in one country has to do
business with another they first have to
exchange their currency to that that to
another country's currency then need to
change that for goods and then need to
go back and forth and every time so it's
kind of like barter in the sense that
you first need to sort of make these
extra transactions but with Bitcoin like
several layers of those transactions
will just get abstracted away and I
believe that sort of this will expand
the economy and accelerate capitalism
and free markets and borderless commerce
even more absolutely so alright here's
what I want to do I want to play devil's
advocate right I want to take the seat
of the Bitcoin detractors the people who
don't believe or think that your view of
the world are wrong is wrong right
and so you I'm going to throw some ideas
out at you in in some detractions and
you kind of respond as you see fit can
Bitcoin go to zero I believe that
theoretically it could but with every
ten minutes that it successfully adds
another block to the blockchain and
doesn't fail the probability of that is
reduced every ten minutes or every
single day okay so there's a nonzero
chance it could happen but the the
addition of time makes it less likely
precisely and this is precisely where a
sort of artist constant discussion of
the effect comes from the longer a piece
of technology like this exists the more
likely it is to persist even more in the
future and the longer it exists it also
gives trust to the people because say
you discard between 2011 a lot of a lot
of us thought oh it's a joke as whatever
we've seen that before right now you
read it again in 2013 you're like oh
this is still not dead in 2015 you're
like oh this is still here now in 20 in
2025 people are going to be oh this
thing is here for almost 20 years
this is here to stay you know and oh
like they've stay still in 20 years
haven't printed any additional Bitcoin
beyond 21 million this is really really
strong you know Bitcoin yeah it's it's
not not just the trust in the security
and not just the trust in sort of the
decentralization but also the trust in
the currency as money is also growing
which is very very important and like as
I've said trust and market cap over the
long term is really the same thing
absolutely if it did fail if it did go
to zero what's the most likely reason
why catastrophic bugs probably once
again as we've said it is software and
software it's it's an increasingly
complex software so many thousands of
lines of code so many things so many
moving parts at the same time and really
unfortunately very few people of that
caliber that are and that are
simultaneously working on these kinds of
technologies right now and so the main
sort of 10 to 15 contributors to the
Bitcoin project are people sometimes we
want once every four or five years they
they they do make mistakes as we've seen
recently with with the bug luckily it
was fixed pretty quickly I there there
will be bugs I mean as I've said this is
a multi-decade project there's a 50 60
year project this is software we're
likely to see 3 4 5 bugs more before
sort of this thing takes over but this
is inevitable and as I like to think
it's better we take care of these things
right now when it's only a couple
hundred billion rather than when it's a
20 trillion dollar system with the
world's economy running on it of course
okay Bitcoin is too volatile to be a
store value so to me
this is like the easiest this is the
easiest sort of piece of myth or
misconception to Paree
because you actually want bit contribute
all time
Bitcoin cannot be go from one dollar to
being the globe the global digital store
value standard global currency without
volatility in fact you desperately want
Bitcoin to be volatile preferably
upwards of course but you do want it to
be volatile especially versus fiat when
you use the term volatile you need to
understand volatile versus bought and
and typically we mean versus the US
dollar right
I think the bitcoins volatility is great
or if you if you zoom out and look over
the last year's especially on a log
chart this volatility has been
predominantly upwards and this
volatility is so good it shows people
that bitcoins strength versus fiat
currencies is strengthening and fiat
currencies per unit of Bitcoin are
weakening and this volatility isn't just
inevitable it's desirable by the time
Bitcoin completely takes over and in the
long term equilibrium but to in a more
practical answer is that as bitcoins are
traded volume growth as bitcoins
liquidity gets deeper as bitcoins order
books become more abundant as more and
more people sort of cognitively
recognize it as there are more hot lers
as there are more users as there's more
infrastructure as there's greater
security and most importantly as as
there's a bigger market cap bitcoins
volatility will decrease so what this
tells me is bitcoin is a net positive
volatile asset right that there's
violent volatility but over a long
period of time it continues to increase
in value and therefore the only way to
go from worthless to worth a lot you
have that volatility that's a good
precisely I mean you can't have all
these trillions of dollars of wealth
stored in one asset flow into another
asset without volatility being there on
the way and
money is really a technology it's a
financial technology that enables us to
do a lot of things and Bitcoin to me is
a far superior technology than any more
interim metal or any state currency and
so people will the world because it is a
superior technology it will win in the
free market and the world will adopt
this better technology and this better
technology will expand everything okay
Bitcoin can't scale the transactions the
block she can't handle the number of
transactions needed for a global
adoption so a lot of people make a very
big mistake they compare they think of a
Bitcoin as exclusively a payment rail
where it's only like one of the six
things it does and they compared to say
Visa or PayPal now Bitcoin the the main
blockchain is sort of the layer one of
the whole system you have to think of
Visa as it's like a layer three or a
layer four of the current status quo of
financial system which is like the
dollar then you have the central banks
then you have the bank commercial banks
then you have sort of like the rails and
then you have sort of Visa or PayPal if
they all sit on top of this thing and so
we will a Bitcoin is also as you might
know developing layer two layer three
solutions already and so those are the
ones that you will eventually need to
compare against Visa and PayPal the base
layer isn't so much as a payments rail
for daily transactions when you're
buying crisps or a cup of coffee but
it's a settlement layer for very big and
very serious transactions that require a
lot of security
eventually I believe the base layer will
be much more expensive than it is today
but rightfully so because most of the
security will come from fees and it will
be large institutions and and sort of
large sort of business transactions
large commercial transactions that will
predominantly and ultimately eventually
be settled on layer one but I believe
that the VAT trillions of transactions
will be occurring on layer two if not
higher as well as possibly on the side
with side chains drive chains etc but my
argument and Nick Carter has put it very
very well
he said these are layer one is not
parcels its container ships so
we they will eventually be used as
settlement for very very big
transactions and if you're compared with
gold for example today do you know how
much it costs and gold right now is a
means of final settlement between
central banks which do what they do once
every several years when moving gold
from Europe to America or vice versa
today takes tens of millions of dollars
and months if not years in time Bitcoin
even if you run the math at the very
equilibrium the price to settle like
several billions of billions of dollars
on a layer one of Bitcoin will still be
orders of magnitude cheaper than you can
do with gold today which is still a huge
huge advantage and all of those daily
sort of small minuscule transactions
that doesn't require hyper security in
hyper decentralization will be done on
much cheaper much faster so layer two
layer three solutions which sacrifice
some security for greater speed and
greater availability etc I think that's
fair that Bitcoin is being compared not
to the US dollar which it is superior to
in a lot of ways yes right but it is
being compared to payment rails that
aren't accurate comparisons precisely
and a lot of people have pointed out
very very well safety in a mousse I
believe was the first one to pointed us
out Bitcoin isn't competing against
venmo
it's not competing against PayPal or
Visa Bitcoin is competing against
central banks or even more precisely
it's competing against the Bank of
International Settlements as a as a
major settlement network for large
transactions as well as against central
banks for currency issues and those are
really the two things where it has a
competitive advantage and those are the
things that you need to be comparing and
not sort of the small value transactions
absolutely okay bitcoin is not accepted
anywhere so I believe that people and
this is sort of sort of what a lot of
people behind Bitcoin cash and it's nano
Ripple etcetera that's light coin even
they don't understand I believe that the
monetary progression and there's a lot
of debate about this but this is sort of
my strong belief is that money has to
move a new pre-money sort of a new
synthetic commodity that has properties
of becoming money it needs to go through
this evolutionary process and if you've
gone my twitter page it's it's pinned
right on the top it sort of shows a
step-by-step progression and I believe
and this is historically what has
happened to gold and silver as well and
I believe is what's going to happen to
money to Bitcoin first it needs to be a
collectible then it needs to become a
store of value then is going to be a
medium of exchange and finally is going
to be a unit of account so the sort of
merchant adoption to me that's more for
later right now we need to develop a
Bitcoin in the criteria that make it as
the best store of value
I believe that Bitcoin right now still
summer between the collectible and the
store value phases but sort of every
every year it's moving ever closer to
the store of value stage early on a lot
of people argue that it was a
collectible for cypherpunks and nerds
anarchists libertarians etc and right
now as we've discussed as market cap is
getting bigger as liquidity is getting
bigger as sort of the comparisons to
gold are becoming ever more obvious as a
market cap increases a bit more as
custody solutions improve it will be
seen more and more as a store of value
now as it grows as we've already
concluded volatility decreases it is my
strong belief that people prefer their
day to day currency ie their medium of
exchange to be relatively priced stable
in terms of purchasing power and that's
why I believe the goal isn't to spend
Bitcoin right now the goal is to make
Bitcoin as good of a store of value as
Bitcoin grows
it's disincentives to spend also a
decrease right now I'm not spending my
Bitcoin I am frankly I'm not going to be
spending my Bitcoin for another 15 years
or more I'm not going to spend my
Bitcoin until it's at least 15 20
trillion dollars in today's terms as
Bitcoin gets bigger say it's reached 20
trillion then the amount of gains in
percentage terms that you can have from
there on until the ultimate future
become less there's there's no longer
going to be the thousand X that's still
possible today the maximum from then on
is going to be like what 5 6 X and at
that point
the disincentives to spend that are very
very present today are no longer there
you know the everybody knows the pizza
story we're in 2011 somebody spent
40,000 bitcoins on a couple of pizzas
and today that could have been like half
a billion dollars or something right
and so a lot of people now know they
don't want to be the pizza guy right and
so right now the key is to optimize
Bitcoin for store value and as more sort
of liquidity purrs into the system we
will optimize a Bitcoin for a medium of
exchange
after I believe the store value
functionality has been more or less
saturated of course in monetary academic
terms the medium of exchange and the
store value functions of money are
inextricably linked but right now I
believe we need to optimize for the
latter and then the former will come
with it today Bitcoin is 21 million
total supply right that is what is
written into the code detractors would
argue that that can change through two
different ways one is if the miners all
agreed to allow an increase in the total
supply or two is a hard fork like a
Bitcoin cash that would incorporate a
different supply schedule would then
have Bitcoin not be 21 million fixed
supply how do you respond to either one
of those yes so the latter is easy to
respond it's like saying does the
printing of Zimbabwe dollars hurt the US
dollar mm-hmm not really in fact I think
over the long term this kind of currency
competition is impossible if Bitcoin is
really not government money that we're
saying this is the only one that you're
allowed to use and that is actually
needs to win in the free market and
Bitcoin still has to win 20 other
contenders before and as it wins these
contenders the trust in those 21 million
becomes ever more and people realize
that these 21 million are much more
precious than all the other stuff and
bitcoin is far far more unique than any
other cryptocurrency in this sense so
once again Bitcoin cash printing their
own 21 million is like if Zimbabwe or
Venezuela prints their currency it
doesn't weaken the US dollar
think it makes us stronger because you
have wealth into the quality one and
over the long-term
I actually think these altcoins are good
for Bitcoin because they're showing that
this is this one is far far stronger and
over longer term periods the way
monetary instruments work is that you
want to risk your wealth as much as
possible and you're incentivized to
instead of like being too contrarian
eventually you want to bet on what's the
most converging asset and people will
eventually the one that's less liquid is
risky riskier to store your wealth in
and eventually I believe that not just
with other financial assets before it
has to fight with gold and fiat it will
first have to predominantly defeat other
cryptocurrencies and to answer your
first question miners aren't in control
of Bitcoin okay full nodes and ie users
are in control of Bitcoin and the user
activated the user activated soft fork
is something that has essentially proved
that more than 93% of miners wanted to
increase the block size in sort of their
way more than 85% of the company's
exchanges wallet providers were on their
side as well essentially all of the even
many of the wealthiest bitcoiners were
on their side however so the the users
and those people running full nodes they
decide what kind of code to run and as
well as what kind of transactions to
approve miners cannot make these changes
to the code without consensus and at the
end of the day Bitcoin is this
impenetrable fortress of full nodes
which really collectively as we've
previously discussed in a p2p network
fashion control the network and I
strongly recommend stop and decrypts
article titled bitcoin is an
impenetrable fortress on - for more
nuance on this topic awesome all right
let's switch to the creation of Bitcoin
right so one of the things that Bitcoin
is able to point to that most other
cryptocurrencies and and even fiat
currencies can
not is that the creator of the system is
unknown right so anonymous to anonymous
etc we don't know if it was a man a
woman a group and there is folklore and
myth around who this may be who do you
think it is should we spend our time
trying to figure out who it is right is
it important and if we do figure out
he/she they is Satoshi is that good or
bad for Bitcoin I have certain
suspicions but I'm not going to I'm not
going to say any names out loud
precisely because nobody knowing who
that is for sure
is what makes Bitcoin so strong and as a
Bitcoin evangelist I am incentivized in
this pseudonymous myth and synonymous
strengths to can to continue going
frankly I don't think that the search
for who the bitcoin creator is is a
productive activity and the fact that it
is still unknown and it is still merely
a thing of theories is once again one of
the dozen things that makes Bitcoin far
stronger than 99% of other
cryptocurrencies absolutely because you
won't say names I think it's completely
fair will you at least tip your hand and
whether you think it is an individual or
a group I think it is one person one
person all right well at some point
somebody's going to get that out of you
sure but I mean there there are there
are sort of six or seven theories on
this topic frankly it really doesn't
matter even if we even if you found out
who it is it doesn't matter you wouldn't
even damage Bitcoin at that point I mean
it's it's good right now that we don't
have any any quote-unquote heads of the
dragon to cut and that nope
there's no single party in control of it
as well as the myth is a nice sort of
cherry on the cake but the story is
almost just as important as the
technology for sure because I mean you
can't have an emergence of this neo
money phenomenon without this cult-like
religious like wave accompanying it
right but um it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter
they're the work that has been done on
bitcoins since 2010 is so immense and
now there are so many contributing
individuals contributing coders can
contributing companies that it wouldn't
even matter
bitcoin is is it is is far bigger than
Satoshi right now absolutely alright
we're going to to read a quick message
from the sponsors and then we'll be
right back alright so what I want to
talk about now I had Travis cling on
right so Travis previously was at Steve
Cohen shop right now he's got a crypto
fund and one of the things that we
talked about was this idea of musical
chairs in the institutional world right
so there's a fixed supply of Bitcoin 21
million and right now the music playing
and everyone is walking or jogging
around the chairs and at some point the
music will stop and people will have to
grab a chair they'll begin to sit down
right and one of the ideas that Travis
presented was this idea that some
institutions aren't gonna wait for the
music to stop they're gonna just start
sitting down right and so he recently
tweeted and said you know look I talked
about musical chairs Yale came out and
it's now public that they've invested in
two separate crypto funds and so Travis
made the point that Yale just sat down
Yale just grabbed their seat the music
hasn't stopped but Yale sat down and
said we're gonna make sure we have a
seat at the table how do you think
institutions central bank's you know
world leaders etc should be thinking
about Bitcoin thinking about how to
diversify assets in the Bitcoin and
possibly even fearing Bitcoin all right
what do you think that kind of rational
thought process should be David Swensen
who's the head of the Yale endowment
company has been the trend setter in the
endowment space as well as the large
asset sort of allocation space for the
last 20 years legend an absolute legend
right now that he has invested in to
crypt of funds I believe
I strongly believe that we will see
other Ivy League syndicates other Ivy
League endowment companies as well as
well as big asset managers and even
hedge funds in general
I'll start dabbling in the space and
it's important to call out so they
invested in funds that aren't just
Bitcoin but it's not like they just went
and bought Bitcoin in you know custody
account yes they invested in funds that
from my understanding a majority will go
into liquid kind of late-stage
opportunities like Bitcoin aetherium etc
but some portion of it will still go
into I SEOs venture capital equity
investments etc right so it's kind of a
broader basket than just Bitcoin but
Bitcoin etherium these liquid cryptos
are a big percentage of the allocation
so obviously if they had just bought
Bitcoin and Bitcoin alone and just put
it in their own custody account that
would be an even bigger deal right but
this is still pretty big deal how do
people respond other than just backing
funds right if you're a central bank
right now what do you do the two best
things to do is to either invest in
Bitcoin directly or to invest in a GP of
one of the top five best funds
the latter given the superiority of the
fund over others might be the single
best decision but and then the third
best is to invest in the LP of the best
funds of course but those three are the
best opportunities I don't quite agree
with the portfolio construction of
without naming any names of the I don't
quite personally agree with the
portfolio construction of the two funds
that are relevant to the story here
mm-hm I believe that a leveraged my
Utley leveraged play on Bitcoin will
have a better Sharpe ratio than dabbling
in alt coins but I think it is I mean I
will personally be having
10 to 15% of my portfolio in 2 or 3
premium I'll coins as well but really my
heart predominantly belongs to Bitcoin
and I believe that at this point in time
from a technological perspective it is
fiduciary irresponsible not to have at
least 60% of your cryptocurrency
portfolio in Bitcoin mmm
my own fund will be engaged in a more
active management but the sort of the
long-term portion of our portfolio will
be predominantly Bitcoin or leveraged
long leveraged place on it and here's
the thing a lot of people perhaps
rightfully believe that this sort of alt
coins game so to speak in this
blockchain project game will still go on
for two or three more cycles and that
might be true and given that that is
true the two funds that we are
discussing they have tremendous pedigree
and tremendous sort of networks that
they can tap into and now the names and
they've got the track records they also
can't really justify putting
three-quarters of their portfolio into
Bitcoin because then essentially many if
not most of their LPS will be able to
just do the same themselves they need to
take advantage of sort of the
opportunities that they have the
tremendous deep discounts on future alt
coins and the future iciar projects that
they will receive undoubtedly and
perhaps even they might some of these
things might outperform Bitcoin in the
near term and thus if they sort of
change their direction at a precise
enough time they might even make more
Bitcoin for the investors that way so I
actually think that something like this
is a strategy a lot of the a lot of sort
of similar people that I've talked to
they believe that there when all is said
and done there will be six or seven
currencies I think that's nonsense
because if you study monetary history
and given sort of the globalised
increasingly fluid increasingly
interconnected and interoperable nature
of these technologies
and the world at large I believe I used
to think it was when I take most as well
I used to think it would be like 70 26
for like in a perrito
distribution type way but I increasingly
believe that it will rather be
winner-take-all rather than when I take
most and I would also say to many of
these investors that you have to you
absolutely have to think of these crypto
assets as money first and software
second a lot of people who come from the
entrepreneurial VC or the technology
world they think of it the other way
they think about it the other way around
and I think that is going to lead to a
lot of losses it's going to lead to a
lot of losses and a lot of even sort of
the premium big hedge funds will will
not perform as well as those who managed
to position themselves in accordance to
more correct monetary theories yeah look
I'll even take it a step further right
in most cases you have more extreme
views than I do
but in this case I may have more than
you in that if you're an institution
today and you have zero exposure to the
cryptocurrency asset class or market
you're violating your fiduciary duty
given that it was the best performing
asset over the last decade right it has
very unique characteristics when it
comes to lower levels of correlation
upside the per unit of risk that you
take by allocating capital here and so
those institutions that are on 0%
exposure have to do what we call get off
zero right each portfolio is different
so some it's ten basis points 50 75 200
500 whatever whatever the basis point
number is it's all about what their
goals are what their current allocations
are all of that but zero is the wrong
number right and so that's much easier I
think for long-term macro investors who
have experience and even expertise in
the alternative space so Dave Swanson is
like a perfect example at Yale but I
think that this is actually true
at the central bank level at the
individual level etc and so let's go
into a hypothetical world where the US
central bank is playing that game of
musical chairs and they sit down and it
comes out that the US central bank
bought five ten percent of the network
on the open market what happens to
Bitcoin the price in kind of the the
macro economic world if that was to come
to light
well then buying five percent would be
impossible what people need to realize
that more than ten more than ten million
of Bitcoin I believe somewhere between
10 to 13 million are like held and not
like actively trading are actively
circulating only 3 to 4 million are
being actively traded and as bitcoins
price will be increasing I believe that
people will be realizing that this is
some there's there's really a financial
revolution going here and this is
something to be kept for a long time
relative to the amount of capital that
are sloshing around in capital markets
around the world Bitcoin is really so
small still right and it's really quite
it's really liquid really and as they
even try to buy half a percent like that
very act will raise the price so much in
a vertical fashion that just buying the
next half a percent will be eight times
more expensive and like this continuous
compounding in an exponential fashion it
will need to be done in an extremely
stealthy in an extremely clever in an
extremely patient manner over months
over years maybe even and maybe even
then they'll only be able to get to two
two and a half percent a ballpark right
here's what I like to say government's
buying Bitcoin really I think they will
be buying Bitcoin last there's two
things I want to say here first of all
government's buying Bitcoin will
essentially be
putting the final nail in the coffin of
reducing their own size by half because
bitcoin is unprintable which we have
discussed how is going to destroy fiat
currencies and bitcoin is increasingly
untac scible I mean the privacy
technologies around these technologies
as you know will also keep improving
rapidly this is inevitable and so I
believe that governments buying Bitcoin
will probably be the latest group of
people to buy them and that will be the
final ultimate credibility because
essentially the biggest competitor is
capitulating something like that will
not just be a rumor something like that
given bitcoins the liquidity will be
extremely difficult to hide I like to
joke that once a in some Asian central
bank oversaw or a sovereign wealth fund
announces that they put in 2 percent of
their assets into a portfolio of blue
blue chip cryptocurrencies it's game
over but it I don't think that central
banks will are really the people by the
time they will try to be accumulating
any of them basically will already be
huge I actually believe and this is one
of the things that my views differ from
many people in the space actually I
actually think that bitcoins are a cent
will be driven predominantly by the
wealthy the three people the three sort
of the three niches of investors that
will sort of make bitcoins price
skyrocket over the coming decades will
be open-minded ultra high-net-worth
individuals it will be savvy funds and
fund managers and it will be I think
politicians and dictators and sort of
these fringe third world second world
individuals who will need this currency
perhaps more than anyone else and I like
to joke that the essentially the people
and the institutions who bitcoin was
designed to destroy will be precisely
the people who will drive bitcoins price
and bitcoin success to the sky because
if you think about it
the people who censor the most need
unsensible currency the most the people
who sees the most need unseasonable
asses the most and of course the people
who print the most need unprintable
currency the most these people every
week you read about some fringe
countries wealthy individuals and
government officials bank accounts in
Switzerland in Luxembourg in the
Caribbean being frozen in America being
blocked transactions being censored and
this technology allows those very
precise people to have unseasonable
store of value where they can
essentially accumulate wealth with
absolutely no one else in the world
being able to take it away from them
so for better or worse this is how free
market instruments and free market
technologies work so it will be of
course used for the good and the bad but
irregardless these very people whose
bitcoins if is fighting against
ideologically will be the same people
who will be helping it financially
absolutely and I tend to think that you
are more right than wrong on that right
ok so before we kind of go into some
rapid-fire questions if an institutional
CIO a central bank Authority a
government leader is listening to this
give me your 60-second pitch to them why
they should buy bitcoin bitcoin is the
soundest hardest currency that has ever
been invented in the history of human
civilization it is this is this
inflation is second to none
its monetary policies known years in
advance and it is becoming increasingly
credible it will also be increasingly a
threat to the very currencies that you
guys control I think getting in before
most other central banks and most other
sovereign wealth funds and most other
rich people will in the next decade will
prove to be one of the smartest
investment decisions and in the course
of human history and if you are able the
countries that are able to stealthily
accumulate bitcoin and adopt Bitcoin
more than other currencies will thrive
in the age of hyper Bitcoin ization
while the other countries that haven't
done so will suffer tremendously long
Bitcoin short the bankers and I think I
think we are in agreement there all
right so you've answered some of these
already but what do you think is your
most controversial thought is is it the
opportunity that exists for bitcoins
though I mean the opportunity for
Bitcoin is better than ever I would say
the risk reward so the reward is
technically low in and of itself is
lower than it was in like 2013 or
whatever but the risks are also
massively reduced we are we already have
200 companies building for this thing
building on the side of this thing
building on top of this thing the number
of engineers involved are ever greater
if you watch this if you watch those
slides and the lectures from scamming
Bitcoin Tokyo that's happening over the
past couple of days the amount of just
genius inventions that are being
potentially added to Bitcoin and the
improvements added to Bitcoin are
incredible and the liquidity today and
the volumes today and the marketability
of the brand today is far greater than
back then so risk reward might might
even be higher I would say the
opportunities still there it's at least
a couple of hundred X and in the very
very long run more than a thousand X so
there's still a lot of wealth to be
created here doing a mildly leveraged to
play via various instruments or
derivatives is a way to boost returns
even further but I believe that the
opportunities are is def is definitely
here and my other controversial opinion
is what I've described is that Bitcoin
isn't necessarily sort of going to be
adopted bottom-up but rather and it's
not necessarily going to be adopted
top-down either but it will really be
the the wealthy who will be adopting it
unfortunately due to the nature of the
world those are the people with the
money and it's the people with capital
who are going to be sort of boosting the
market capitalizations of these assets
absolutely what's the most important
company in crypto right now chain code
labs why
they have some of the most prolific
developers and block stream as well of
course got it so those working on
Bitcoin yes John Newbery Alex Markos
Matt Corallo they're just on a whole
nother level of genius absolutely all
right if you had a magic wand and you
could wave it what's the one regulation
that you would improve or change I would
reduce taxes and I would privatize a lot
more things around the world interesting
I believe that free-market capitalism
and individual entrepreneurs are much
more efficient at providing solutions
and a much more efficient at making what
Austrian economists call economic
calculations in a very in very very
crude terms a thousand clever smart
talented entrepreneurs with a million
dollars each will do a lot more both for
themselves and the world then just a
baroque rat an emotionless baroque rot
with no connection to that particular
money will do with the billion dollars
and I believe that a lot of the things
that governments do around the world
today if you privatize or even partially
prioritize those things the world will
be much more efficient because
essentially seven fiercely competitive
companies will always achieve the result
much better than one sort of
bureaucratic fat government institution
so to speak I don't think anyone is
surprised that you believe that and I
tend to I tend to agree most most
fastest there
okay so let's talk about something for
two minutes that's non crypto related so
aliens right we just got to admit that
they exist most people think of aliens
as a human equivalent right they're
depicted that way in movies and sci-fi
etc but nobody ever really talks about
alien animals right do we think that
there are multiple species of aliens and
if so do we think aliens have pets well
if you make the assumption in aliens
exist and it is likely then many
different kinds of aliens exist right
just due to the vastness of space
statistically speaking this vastness is
so immense that if we do go off of the
assumption that at least once be one
other species exists it is likely that
hundreds of others do as well
and it is also likely that several
species exist on sort of one planet or
ecosystem flora fauna or whatever
together and I wouldn't be surprised if
those civilizations have animals as well
yeah yeah you think they have pets
though you think they take the animals
and they make them their pets boss and
like a domesticated it is hard to say
some of the alien species would have
pets I think probabilistically speaking
that's very likely it really depends
sort of on the on the culture and in the
order of that particular world yeah yeah
I think that's fair
all right so I'll let ind to one of
these with allowing the guests to ask me
one question what one question do you
have for me I guess you've asked this
question to me but I would like to sort
of hear your version as well I know if
we've already previously talked about
this but I just sort of like to rehash
these bullet points in my head as well
you personally and sort of on with your
work with Morgan Creek and other
ventures how do you go about pitching
Bitcoin and sort of this ecosystem at
large to not individual investors but
the more conservative large asset
allocators yeah look I think that it's
custom given who we're talking to right
so there's kind of different things that
we emphasize or de-emphasize depending
who are talking to a lot of it it is
informed by who they are what their
current allocation is what their goals
are etc but there are some common
threads through each conversation right
one of them is this asset class has some
of the highest yield opportunities per
unit of risk across the entire world
right any asset any asset class any
strategy this is one of if not the
highest potential yield per unit of risk
that's one - is that the idea of
scarcity around Bitcoin specifically is
something that they have likely not
thought deeply about nor do they
actually under
and the gravity of the implications so
it's one thing to just understand okay
if there's a fixed supply an increase in
demand price should appreciate it's
another thing to understand 21 million
bitcoins exist and there are hundreds of
trillions of dollars of wealth in the
world that are going to be competing for
those 21 million hundreds of trillions
of dollars exist and so if you manage
500 million a billion ten billion a
hundred billion you're nobody and if you
don't have your seat at the table now
you may not get a seat later right so
there's a second one and then the third
one is we actually make a economic
argument looking at other asset classes
so the opportunity cost if you do not
invest in cryptocurrencies Bitcoin
blockchain etc what else is out there
and what you find depending on who you
listen to right my mind partner mark
usko is is very well versed in have the
endowment model and comes out of that
world and he walks people through this
idea that the yield that they target or
goal on may not be available in other
asset classes right so if you look at
stocks bonds currencies and commodities
only for assets that you can own the
ability to drive six and a half seven
seven and a half eight percent
annualized yield may not be there over
the next decade and so if that is true
that doesn't necessarily mean you should
take a hundred percent of your assets
and go put it into Bitcoin for example
but you should have exposure right and
so those three core components make up
this kind of verbal campaign that we're
on called get off zero right and it's
the idea that if you are sitting in a
fiduciary seat and you have a zero
exposure to the asset or the asset class
they're wrong right there's a
qualitative argument there's a
quantitative argument we're happy to
discuss either one of them but you're
wrong
zero is the wrong number you
have to get off zero and so whether it's
ten basis points 50 100 500 that's a
customized conversation for who it is
what their goals are with the current
allocation etc but zero is the wrong
answer and what we find is that specific
argument of you have no skin in this
game and this could be the most
important game available really
residents right and so I think that Yael
jumping in very big deal right we've got
some institutions that I think when
people find out are gonna be shocked
right and again more people grabbing
seats I think what we are going to see
over the next I put out like 36 months
is a a FOMO or a just an inflow of
capital from very very sophisticated
people that most of the financial world
is not expecting right so there's a I
think as Bill Gates says you know we
overestimate what we can accomplish in
two years and we underestimate what we
accomplish in 10 years I'm probably with
you in that even the most hardcore
Bitcoin believers are actually
drastically under estimating what we're
talking about here and what the
potential is and if that is true this is
the most important piece of technology
that the world seen without a doubt and
those are amazing points to add to the
discussion on yield I would say um one
of my old bosses told me that making
money for you guys will in general as an
aggregate as a demographic will be much
harder than it was for our generation or
the generation before that and as you're
as you might know in the 50s or 60s you
could have just a regular job and still
be able to buy one house or even two
houses have a big family et cetera
today that's that's impossible the world
not just America but the world as a
whole is becoming fiercely competitive
we are sort of obviously not at the end
of the s-curve but we are sort of it's
kind of sloping down innovations are
harder to
create the technologies are more
sophisticated to sort of incrementally
push further and the amount of I guess
ideas that are easy pickings are scarce
err nowadays I generally like obviously
getting becoming wealthy takes a decade
at least or more for anybody but I like
to say semi jokingly that crypto might
be the last easy way to get rich in my
generation look I am we obviously today
have you know the richest man in the
world over a hundred billion dollars of
wealth named Jeff Bezos it would not
surprise me that the richest company in
the world right which is over a trillion
today is matched by the richest person
in the world in the future so we'll have
a trillionaire and the odds of that
person comes from the cryptocurrency
world in my opinion is the highest
probability out of any other industry
and so if that is true the amount of
millionaires sent to millionaires
billionaires sent to billionaires that
will be created in this asset class will
be unparalleled in anything else in
history and so I think that's part of
the excitement for sure in monetary
terms within that particular asset
Bitcoin will actually increase
inequality because the way it is is the
the distribution is improving with every
cycle of course but if hyper bit
colonization were to actually occur the
Gini coefficient of Bitcoin would
probably be higher than any fiat
currency today among the predominant
ones so we would definitely see some of
trillion a couple of trillion Aires in
today terms I think without a doubt
absolutely all right man this is uh this
is epic I really really appreciate the
time I hope that this is valuable to
everybody and
and what to do this pretty regularly -
what to check back in and see kind of
how how all this is progressing so thank
you for sure thanks for having me
absolutely
[Music]